und den prozess in magdeburg verfolgt
für uns jörg völkerling guten morgen
jörg ja die familie sollte ja heute im
gericht erscheint sie wollte aber nicht
da gab es ein ganz schönes hin und her
was kannst du uns dazu sagen die eltern
claudia und roland walli jetzt und die
tochter adp hätten sich diesen gern
heute morgen gerne erspart sie hatten im
vorfeld des prozesses drei
gleichlautende erklärungen beim
verteidiger von stefan bald in den
briefkasten geworfen und erklärt sie
würden von ihrem
zeugnisverweigerungsrecht gebrauch
machen und ihr ihren stefan nicht
belasten
es fehlte allerdings der absender auf
dem briefumschlag in formaler fehler den
sich die nebenklage anwälte nun vor
allen dingen zu nutze machen denn ihn
geht es hier im prozess ja darum auch
das umfeld von stefan bald aufzuklären
die frage zu stellen wie wurde er
geprägt wurde er vielleicht auch von
seiner mutter beeinflusst
und auch stephan pariert selbst hätte es
glaube ich diesen morgen sich gerne
erspart das wiedersehen in aller
öffentlichkeit mit seinen eltern denim
kann es nicht daran gelegen sein dass
hier auch die weiche seite von ihm zur
sprache kommt denn auch darüber hatten
die eltern in polizeivernehmung
berichtet zum beispiel dass stefan baldi
hat am vorabend der tat seine mutter
noch beim bügeln half dass er insekten
rettete und dass er seine waffen im
kinderzimmer dass er sein kinderzimmer
nur deswegen abgeschlossen habe damit
sein vierjähriger neffe diese beim
stöbern nicht finde
was ist denn so spannend an der aussage
der eltern
nun ja wir haben selbst einen eindruck
davon bekommen vom weltbild der familie
verliert kurz nach der tat nur stunden
war mein kollege thilo scholtyseck beim
vater der beschrieb seinen sohn als
eigenbrötler der fast nur online
unterwegs gewesen sei der weder mit sich
selbst noch mit der welt im reinen
gewesen sei dabei muss ja auch roland
barthes mitbekommen habe wie sein sohn
mit diesem 3d drucker bei ihm zuhause
experimentierte ständig in der werkstatt
aktiv waren
claudia bald eine ethik lehrerin an der
grundschule in helbra sagte einem team
von spiegel tv nur stunden nach dem
amoklauf in halle
ihr sohn habe ja nichts gegen die juden
an sich sondern nur gegen die leute die
hinter der finanziellen macht stünden
und dann sagt diesen satz wer hat das
nicht und im prozess hier wurde gestern
ein abschiedsbrief verlesen von ihr sie
wollte sich das leben nehmen und darauf
hätte hatte sie einen davidstern
gezeichnet und ihnen danach selbst
durchgestrichen und gesagt sie und ihr
sohn seien ein opfer dieser
heuchlerischen welt ihr sohn habe nur
für die wahrheit gekämpft und wer wird
heute noch aussagen
insgesamt sind heute am vierten
prozesstag im landgericht magdeburg acht
zeugen geladen für die eltern ist die
erste halbe stunde ab 10 uhr vorgesehen
ist wird damit gerechnet dass sie nur
ihre personalien angeben und dann wieder
gehen brisant ist dass sie dann auch
darauf bestehen können dass sämtliche
von ihnen bisher gemachten
zeugenaussagen nicht im prozess
verwertet werden dürfen und auch
vernehmungsbeamte nicht darüber aussagen
dürfen
danach kommen dann schulfreunde aus
helbra die ihn erlebt haben die ihn als
eigenbrötler erlebt haben wir selber
haben ja auch mit welchen gesprochen die
gesagt haben auch im schulbus saß er im
abseits
und es kommen wohl auch noch kameraden
aus seiner bundeswehrzeit wo er seine
ersten erfahrungen mit der waffe gemacht
hat